[Música]
me encantaría conectar
[Aplausos]
con todos nosotros levantando la mano
todos los que alguna vez comenzamos a
leer un libro pero por algún motivo
nunca lo terminamos
oigan pero dejen arriba es que hay
varios llamados levantaron seguros que
tenemos que ser terminado todos los
libros
yo creo que yo creo que a todos nos ha
pasado o alguna dieta por ejemplo en año
nuevo quien se propuso una dieta y al
paso de unos días o unas semanas se
rindieron venga levanten la mano porque
creen que esto pasa porque es creen que
esto pasa
porque claudicamos procrastinar nos
desviamos de los trans meta de nuestros
sueños
pero es quiero platicar hoy porque creo
que esto sucede y miren creo que hay
tres factores principales el primero le
llamo sueños impropios los sueños hacen
lo que muchos de nosotros nos la pasamos
buscando satisfacer los deseos de
alguien más viviendo la vida para
algunas muchas veces sus padres
los demás nos encontramos
2 vivimos encajados vivimos dentro de
una caja nos cuesta mucho trabajo salir
seguimos patrones morales religiosos
sociales políticos
y este ejemplo me encanta porque
imagínense ustedes en la mañana cuando
tienen que tomar la decisión de qué
zapatos se van a poner
y nos cuesta muchísimo trabajo decidir
entre si luego en los zapatos que me
encantan
o me pongo los zapatos que tengo que
ponerme para pertenecer encajar o ser
aceptado en mi comunidad
en el primero respondemos una persona en
el segundo respondemos un colectivo
y el tercero para mí es el más delicado
porque es el momento en el que creo que
los primeros dos ya no manipularon por
tanto tiempo al grado que ya no sabemos
reconocer si esos sueños que estamos
persiguiendo en realidad son nuestros o
son de algunas
indefensión a 3
miren para mí todo esto se remonta a la
forma en la que fuimos educados y es que
me atrevería a decir la mayoría de
nosotros tuvimos una escuela tradicional
esto quiere decir que la metodología con
la cual nos educaron estaba inspirada en
la revolución industrial
lo que querían y buscaban era
estandarizar el perfil del alumno o sea
todos nosotros querían que fuéramos
iguales
porque porque lo que crean es que
saliéramos de los graduados y que nos
pudiéramos alinear a la línea de
producción justamente las fábricas y yo
continuaremos
pero con lo que no contaron en aquel
entonces e inclusive hoy en día porque
estas metodologías siguen vigentes hoy
en muchas de nuestras instituciones
lo que nos contaron entonces y ahora es
honesto
nuestra huella digital
todos nosotros somos seres únicos
auténticos irrepetibles no hay un javier
igual a mí ahí afuera de maialen igual a
ti aquí no existe
en aquellas aulas nunca nos permitieron
crear imaginar proponer cuestionar
esperanzas lo único que podíamos hacer
era obedecer al dictador o la dictadura
que se paraba frente a nosotros y nos
dictaba la elección del diario
miren a lo largo de nuestro desarrollo
no solamente en las aulas o en las
escuelas se nos van sumando amistades
las personas que nos comienzan a dictar
el como pelado como éste como hablar
nos dictan hasta el cómo vivir al grado
que nos van formando imagen y semejanza
de una masa y luego amanecemos un buen
día y nos cuestionamos porque me siento
desilusionado
pero es que con qué ilusión se vive una
vida falsa
con qué ilusión vives tú una vida falsa
y este cuestionamiento nos llega a todos
en distintas etapas de nuestra vida pero
sobre todo nos llega en ese momento en
el cual de buenas a primeras nos piden
elegir elegir elegir la profesión a la
que te vas a dedicar elegir la pareja
con la cual vas a compartir el resto de
tu vida te piden elegir cuando hasta
entonces no habías podido decidir nada
y es que es bien importante
que dentro de este ejercicio
cuestionemos las ciudades heredadas esas
ideas y saber y validar si realmente son
nuestras
o bien de alguien más porque como lo que
como porque solamente leí los libros que
me asignaron en la escuela o la que más
me gusta porque me sigo juntando con
esas amistades que no me dejan ser yo
y dentro de todo este cuestionamiento me
encantaría que se pregunten quiénes son
de dónde vienen a dónde van porque están
aquí para que yo quisiera cuestionarme
con ustedes quién es una persona feliz
quien es feliz y también tienes una
persona exitosa
y luego entonces si es que una persona
que ha alcanzado el éxito por
consecuencia es una persona feliz si la
respuesta es que sí y una vez que yo
haya alcanzado el éxito y en
consecuencia soy feliz entonces he
alcanzado la vida plena
digo un putt
la felicidad
viene ligada al éxito o sea una vez que
yo alcance el éxito entonces seré feroz
véanlo así cuando yo me subo a la
báscula en la mañana y baje de peso seré
feliz cuando consiga pareja seré feliz
cuando traiga mucho dinero en la bolsa
seré
feliz feliz irónicamente solamente
funciona en ese orden o por lo menos
parece que ha sido así
lo que quiere decir que si yo quiero ser
feliz antes de haber alcanzado una meta
o mi éxito entonces no puedo hacerlo
miren la felicidad es un estado de ánimo
de gozo
poco con eso temporal
lo irónico es que la felicidad que todos
nosotros estamos persiguiendo allá
afuera es permanente
y por otro lado el éxito el éxito es
como la salida de la conclusión de
algunos de nuestros proyectos o tareas
de manera satisfactoria que por lo
general trae consigo reconocimiento y
reconocimiento que a la vez genera en mí
una sensación sensación de felicidad y
es que es por esto que para mí el
objetivo amigas y amigos no es buscar en
la vida el éxito ni la felicidad porque
el éxito solamente me las sensaciones de
ser feliz y la felicidad pues es
pasajera
para mí el objetivo se llama serenidad
la serenidad que me ayuda con el manejo
de mis emociones
la serenidad que me da la fortaleza y la
calma ahora si es permanente si yo lo
deseo
la serenidad que pudiese llegar a ser mi
estado ideal porque me permite dejar mis
impulsos a un lado para comenzar a
disfrutar de mis más grandes alegrías y
hasta comenzar a valorar
la premisa que hay detrás de los más
profundos tristes
y esque
esto no significa que yo vaya a ser una
persona insensible no significa que
cuando mi hijo llegue darle sus primeros
pasos o diga papá por primera vez no me
vaya a conmover y ayudar
de dominar
por las ilusiones que se les presentan
y porque creo que la serenidad es la
clave porque qué pasa si nunca llegas a
la meta o qué pasa si la meta que estás
trabajando buscando no es como la punta
este de origen
imaginen que la empresa que fundaron con
tanto sacrificio y tanto amor de pronto
se enfrente a una crisis económica a una
catástrofe natural tal vez o porque no a
una pandemia global
y en medio de todo este caos resulta que
aparte muere uno de nuestros seres
queridos
y resulta que entonces nada de lo que
han logrado
nada de lo que hasta ahora se ha
alcanzado puede consolarse esto te
quiebra y tu vida incluso comienza a
perder sentido
miren para muchos esto es el fondo es
como una caída libre de la cual
difícilmente fueron de recuperación
aquí es cuando la seriedad entra te
sostiene y te permite vivir las
emociones al momento pero con templanza
y es que la vida todos vamos a caer
pero para mí lo importante es hacer
miren yo crecí siendo uno de esos niños
tímidos introvertidos pero se escondía
tras de mamá al llegar a las fiestas
civera de los niños callados en el salón
de clases y tengo que platicarles y
compartirles que sufrí muy bien como
creo muchos de ustedes
sí como víctima y también como abusador
tratando de entender y quiero
compartirles que en ninguna de esas
facetas nunca me sentí satisfecho o
pleno nunca de hecho creo que eso es lo
que me motivó para hacer distintas
introspección es a lo largo de mi
infancia y darme cuenta que en mi
interior era un ser maravilloso pero no
solamente yo
y esta es una realidad no solamente yo
me di cuenta que también mis compañeros
que muchas veces se burlaron de mí y de
los cuales yo también me burlé eran
seres increíbles y estamos perdidos
nuestro tiempo haciéndolos - unos a los
otros
yo pienso
y muchas veces me preguntaron no podía
llegar a la conclusión de cómo es que
esto había pasado
pero yo pienso mucho en el momento en el
que tome la edición
de comenzar a hacer que yo quería hacer
y no que los demás aspirantes yo fuera y
es que a partir de ese momento es que yo
comencé a disfrutar oa vivir la aventura
más grande de mi vida
la aventura de conquistar mi cada día
tratar de alcanzar la mejor versión que
dices
y muchas veces de cuestionar y de hombre
para cómo pasó esto nos da
un tema divino es
y la realidad es que no fue así me di
cuenta que en el fondo mi madre tenía
mucho que ver la formación que me dio mi
familia mi padre mi madre no profesar un
apoyo incondicional y constante y sigue
siendo hasta el de hoy nosotros tu madre
me dio la oportunidad a mí a mis
hermanos de vivir una formación muy
flexible independiente de la educación
tradicional que lleva en la escuela en
mi casa tuve la oportunidad de probar de
todo desde muy temprano y desde muy
joven yo tenía la oportunidad de probar
todo lo que lo propusieron no importaba
el talento lo que importaba era la
intención
desde muy jovencito a los cinco años ya
corría coches de carreras andaba en moto
jugaba para el americano y si gimnasia
olímpica cante toqué el piano y podría
continuar el punto no es ese el punto es
que desde esa edad y ese entonces yo ya
había ganado distintas competencias las
había ganado y había triunfado y se
siente a todo creando se siente todo no
saben qué más me dio la oportunidad mi
madre de vivir con todas estas pruebas
me dejó vivir desde aquel entonces desde
muy pequeño la oportunidad de ser un
perdedor
porque en ese camino para haber
triunfado perdí más veces de las que ya
había ganado y esto me permitió vivir lo
que hoy llamamos residencia una palabra
que comprendí hasta muchos años después
pero en ese entonces yo ya había
enfrentado la advertir a la adversidad
había salido recompuesto de la misma
pero sobre todo con un aprendizaje de
eso
y nosotros crecemos con una fórmula y
normalmente la establecemos círculo
buscamos metas con las cuales trabajamos
las cuales imprimimos disciplina y es
simple esa disciplina que le ponemos
normalmente nos lleva al éxito si el
problema es que si me remonto al
principio de la charla y esa meta la
cual estoy trabajando la que quiero
conseguir si no es mía si es producto de
un sueño en propio o de vivir encajado
pues difícilmente es que quiero en otra
parte cuando me dicen y javier y con un
lease para si alguien tan disciplinado y
para conservar esa motivación siempre
les inventa una respuesta pero la mente
se nos sucede a pensar mucho a notar y
llegar a esta conclusión con sido algo
no pero al final es que me di cuenta que
la gente cuando está tratando de
alcanzar una meta que no es de ustedes
que no es nuestra pues difícilmente te
hace disciplinar y no hacia el éxito
pero hay un tercer ejemplo el cual les
hablaba que la indefensión aprendida y
es que si yo trabajo para una meta que
pienso en el fondo que sí es mi
ajustadísima vaya disciplinar
y es posible que a lo mejor si vais a
alcanzar el éxito
pero a lo mejor ese éxito al cual llegue
imagínense que soy un médico no me
gradué como médico tengo mi práctica y
son sumamente exitosos pero es una
profesión heredada soy médico como mi
papá a los tíos y todos en el fondo si
en tu masivo porque llegan los fines de
semana y yo aún me extraño el rock and
roll mi hermano porque en el fondo lo
que yo era era músico louis trasto que
mi esencia
para mí la solución aquí es dónde está
el grado del éxito y para mí la solución
es invertir esta fórmula descomponer la
y comenzar por el ser auténtico creo que
todos nosotros tenemos que encontrar esa
autenticidad para definir entonces
cuáles son mis metas y poder trabajar
sobre ellas y poderlas alcanzar y de esa
forma o de esa forma alcanzar lo que
llamamos nosotros éxito felicidad no
miren
yo creo que
para mí es muy importante
identificar la autenticidad como una
roca es algo general
porque cuando tú te conviertes en una
persona auténtica
tú vas a dejar fuera todo lo que no
tiene que ver contigo y solamente va a
quedar espacio para ser quien tú en
realidad eres
y yo quiero que ustedes hoy piensen eso
porque ser auténticos
nos va a llevar
a desarrollar un amor o un profundo amor
por la vida
y unas tremendas ganas por explorarla
y con ustedes enamoran de la vida y de
su ser
es que entonces ustedes van a
desarrollar una pasión pero no una
pasión común que una cosa su pasión ya
no va a ser el fútbol
por lo que sea que les mueve su pasión
va a ser su vida su pasión va a ser la
forma de un estilo de vida
y cuando ustedes viven de manera
apasionada con mucho amor por lo que
hacen es que ustedes van a empezar a
desarrollar habilidades de las que nunca
se hubiera imaginado que eran capaces
habilidades que les van a ayudar con la
resolución de conflictos y los problemas
que se nos presentan en el día a día
y cuando tenés esa capacidad para
resolver los conflictos cotidianos
inclusión así vas a pensar una visión
muy clara porque ya sabes quién eres
ya sabes a dónde vas ya sabes lo que
quieres
vas a pasar una visión de la cual
difícilmente alguien te va a visual
y con eso en claro ahora si me da pie
para llegar a la motivación y a la
disciplina que tanto nos cuesta
y es que saben que hoy concluir que la
motivación de la cual tanto me preguntan
basta con el simple hecho de levantarme
la mañana
cuando es así
basta con el simple hecho de estar vivo
me mueve y la disciplina es que la
disciplina es algo tan sencillo cuando
dejas de hacer las cosas por obligación
por sacrificio
para satisfacer alguien más
la disciplina se convirtió en un acto de
voluntad para mí es el amor
reglas más por amor
y la meta si se fijan que la función del
final esta fachada porque al final la
meta ya la viví
nos va
realmente es el proceso constante la
transformación del isr
y pongo checkpoint porque creo que las
metas son muy lejanas y nunca se
alcanzan como son vean siempre objetivos
cortos al corto plazo que los mantengan
satisfechos y al final su meta es vivir
así en autenticidad a mí me encantaría
cerrar dejándoles una advertencia
y es que el camino al ser auténticos
muchas veces se confunde con egoísmo ojo
con esto
y esto nos va a alejar de muchas
personas inclusive de algunos seres
queridos
porque ustedes van a dejar de responder
a sus expectativas
pero créanme cuando yo les digo
que será auténtico nos va a acercar con
las personas que realmente vale la pena
vivir
[Aplausos]